Willow Shields has long been active in
charity work too she's worked in
particular to end bullying in its many
forms and is an advocate for people to
live their lives how they please in 2011
she designed a t-shirt for blue shirt
day an anti-bullying event organized by
stomp out bullying she's also an
advocate for delete digital drama an
anti-cyberbullying nonprofit her
advocacy for anti-bullying is also
likely self-motivated as she was under a
lot of pressure and criticism to play
Prim a certain way and received her fair
share of Internet bullying in addition
to anti-bullying activ is M Shields
advocates for Operation Smile a
nonprofit that helps children born with
clued pallets she also works with The
Thirst project an initiative bringing
clean drinking water to impoverished
children she's aided efforts to help
victims of natural disasters provide
food for impoverished or homeless
families mitigate the effects of climate
change on forests and promote awareness
of gun violence and mass school
shootings